On a sunny
morning at Disney's Animal Kingdom
theme park,
the meerkats
come outside to catch some rays.
They like to lay in the sun.
Some people call them solar powered,
so they sit like this
with their little bellies up to the sky.
You'll see them kind of sitting
in the sun, taking it in, especially early
in the morning on those cooler mornings,
or if it's been kind of raining.
There's so much
I love about working with the meerkats.
I try not to pick favorites.
I love all the meerkats very much,
and they all are very special.
Hi, buddy.
You are so cute.
I know.
I love you.
Can't favor you on camera.
That's just embarrassing.
These Southern African desert dudes
love their creepy crawly snacks.
So today I'm feeding the meerkats,
super worms and mealworms.
And they definitely love
those super worms is their favorite snack.
I've been working with them
for a really long time.
That means that I've been able to learn
all their individual quirks
and personalities,
and so I can sort of
tell them apart by what they're doing.
Thomas Arlo.
Springsteen. Bentley
Nirvana.
Newt.
At this moment in time, I would say that
Newton is probably our dominant animal.
Which is surprising to me
because he's one of our youngest animals.
Being the dominant male matters
in the meerkat market.
Your job is kind of determined
in some ways by your social ranking
within the group.
So in a typical group,
there would be a dominant female
who selects the dominant male
and they breed,
and then the other members of the mob
are responsible for raising the offspring,
finding food, taking sentry duty, which
means lookout to keep everybody safe.
All of that kind of stuff
falls on the other members of the group.
Bentley’s in the back.
They're scanning the sky
and the surrounding area to make sure
there are no threats that are imminent,
that everybody needs to be aware of.
Bentley is a really fun guy.
He is very chill.
I would say he's really calm
and easygoing for the most part.
Oh, so that was an alarm call.
Looks like he might have seen something
in the sky that I cannot see.
They have a specific vocalization
for a sky
predator versus land predator.
Something happened.
We're all seeking shelter.
Oh. We're scared of the zebra.
Those are our neighbors.
You all know the zebra.
We're all underground.
When the coast is clear, lower ranking
Bentley comes out with some attitude.
Bentley is definitely not in charge
and when it comes to our meerkat
social rankings.
But sometimes he likes to try it out
and see how high he can get
and test the waters.
But there's something brewing potentially.